so I've had a very love hate
relationship with Netflix movies of late
Kodachrome had me feel a lot of
different ways first off in the menu of
Netflix it says it's a comedy / drama it
is not a comedy whatsoever just because
Jason Sudeikis is in it do not be fooled
this is a full-on drama it's heavy it's
a tearjerker I mean it gets really
depressing and I did not see that coming
first half dragged a bit took a little
while to get going I think it had a
little too much setup here right when
Jason Sudeikis got to Chicago to lock in
this band that's where this movie start
getting really really good and didn't
let go I know so this whole record label
theme was very effective I think it
worked and it felt very current with our
times and now he was a guy was all about
authenticity and showing that angle he
wasn't selling out his soul so that felt
unique in a way to give the character
something he does from very updated
stance as a record label producer he's
not just trying to make money he's a guy
in this world that doesn't want him
anymore he clearly doesn't want guys
like him anymore trying to fight through
it and Zoe played by elizabeth Olsen who
I never knew was also the younger sister
of the Olsen twins was great here her
character is really necessary and worked
really well as the nurse of Ed Harris
and I like that the reveal about her
that she had skeletons too and that she
was the cheater in her divorce not her
husband so she was almost afraid to
commit to people because she doesn't to
hurt them which we've all met people
like that and it worked cuz her and
jason sudeikis characters had great
chemistry both had a lot of fear in them
and at first it seemed a little like oh
yeah of course they're gonna get
together but it still had to happen cuz
it really worked well when it got going
their attention how built up and how it
wrapped around them and how really his
dad brought them together I would say he
even had that in mind and this proved
Jason Sudeikis I wasn't sure how I would
feel about him doing a serious role he
did really good
I was super shocked here I believed
every scene he knew where he was what he
was thinking at any given moment and
didn't overact
and it's really hard to hang with a
legend like Ed Harrison he did his job
the music was also really good in this
movie a lot of songs you can notice and
it represented the main character really
well my favorite scene has to be when ed
Harris's character finally breaks and
cries to his son in the hospital really
really hard to watch really worked not
for the faint of heart
and that Harris wasn't mailing it in
sometimes movies like this low-budget
Netflix you'll see big actors sometimes
kind of just get through
but our Harris I felt gave 100% again
what complain have is they could have
really chopped out a lot in the
beginning here they start with a little
humor especially when was in the office
jason sudeikis and just didn't really
work well to me just get to the
Kodachrome point why he needs to go and
help his dad you don't have to show so
much baxter with him the office just get
it a little quicker also the scenes felt
a little off when the group was at Jason
Davis's uncle's house when Ed Harris
just brought up randomly that he slept
with his brothers and I know the guys a
bad guy but he's not that evil I mean
that is so low and that even felt out of
character for him that whole scene was
weird to me there was no resolution
between those family members who aren't
main characters but they kind of built
them up a little bit and you started
liking them and they just left the
kitchen and we never saw him again
so that kind of felt out of nowhere and
not necessary just to show how evil this
guy is and I don't think it worked I'd
rather just take that scene out cuz it
took a little bit of the realism away
from me and some of the dialogue
especially in scenes like this were too
on-the-nose and just moments are like no
one would talk like this not a lot but a
little bit in this movie but the ending
really paid off if you're patient at the
beginning the second half was a joy to
watch it was a good sad story and
convincing that he would like his father
at the end and that'll even this
underlying love he had for his son
outweighed it all in the end and that
love can always come back out of nowhere
even though the father can't be a good
father in the right way he still loves
his son and wanted the best for him and
I like how it resolved where he got the
girl at the end and how they both had
their separate relationships with Ed
Harris and when you have three really
good characters and three really good
actors you really can't go wrong I think
for a Netflix movie this was pretty damn
good I'm gonna give it an 8 let me know
what you thought of it down below I
respond to everybody please subscribe I
do a bunch of movie reviews TV reviews
celebrity interviews and free giveaways
so you don't wanna miss any of those and
I'll see you next time